the singularity well I mean that's just
something that that we just don't
understand it's a singular point and
that means the curvature of the
space-time at this point has gone
infinite and all the mass has collapsed
to one point so it's a point literally a
point with this mass in there so it's
got infinite density you know density is
mass per unit volume well if it's got no
volume it's it's it's an infinite
density they use black holes that are
defined or defined in the sense of using
general relativity and this is this
wonderful theory of Einstein which
explains how matter in curvature of
space-time are intricately linked
together so you really need something
quantum theory of gravity to try to
describe that so and I'm sure that a
quantum theory of gravity will resolve
the question of what the singularity is
at the center of a black hole it's just
that we don't know what that is yet so
that solution as it stands is there
classically but when you include the
world of quantum mechanics where things
gets can get smeared out what isn't
clear is whether that singularity will
remain or maybe it will get smeared out
will this event horizon still be there
so will that what we think of as the
black hole still be there I probably
will
what's that area like between the event
horizon and the singularity is it like a
is that a tumultuous place or do you not
know yet like almost like there but I /
hurricane if you're heading into the
black hole and if this is a big enough
black hole you actually don't even know
you cross this event horizon it in fact
the density of the of the black hole
around the event horizon for a really
massive black hole is of order water
that water and so you just sort of pass
through but what what begins to happen
is you you begin to experience the
gravitational attraction it begins as
you get closer and closer to the
singularity this it gets bigger and
bigger and so you will begin to stretch
and you will begin to feel the effects
of the pull of the black hole and
forever but on the other hand for a soul
of mass black hole you know one minute
of order this the mass of the Sun then
the pull of gravity on the event horizon
is much stronger and you will have
already been
spaghetti fide by the time you cross the
event run you won't see the event
horizon there's not there's no signpost
saying you know event horizon no return
but you will you will pass through this
you will have all already be gone in
terms of living by then but a
supermassive black hole you actually
won't even realize it's the the pole is
is far less and the density of the
matter is far less and significant there
than it would be in the smaller black
hole great is a good question okay so if
the black hole's big it was a big black
hole like maybe the one in the center of
the Milky Way then you know when it
crosses the event horizon well I live
forget firewalls for a second but it
went across the event horizon you
general you'd expect nothing much to
happen because actually the
gravitational fields pretty weak out
there as you start to go deeper and
deeper inside the side this black hole
you might think that indeed does it
retain its state as a particle I would
say probably not because then you know
you're entering that regime where even
your theory of gravity is breaking down
well let's let's think how an electron
became an electron
okay so so where does the electron get
its mass from I guess it's mass from
from the Higgs particle from the Higgs
higgs field actually more appropriately
and for that for it to get its mass from
the higgs field something has to happen
called spontaneous symmetry breaking
assumed to have to be broken now if you
restore that symmetry and that symmetry
does get restored at high energies then
the electron loses its mass and you know
you can't really talk about eventually
the electron just becomes part of some
greater thing and that's what would
happen is I think as you approach the
the black hole singularity things would
just simply be restored you would no
longer be able to describe matter in
terms of what we think of the low energy
and matter dynamics you would have to
replace that by some high energy version
of it and eventually you'd have to
replace things ultimately by the full
quantum theory of gravity and everything
ie maybe string theory really talking
about strings so you would never even
talk about the no like you can't talk
about electron very very close to
singularity you don't even have a single
arity really you've probably got some
sort of string G type structure of which
that electron has now become part and is
itself some stringy excitation we do not
know how to
you use gravity and quantum mechanics in
regimes where gravity is incredibly
strong and quantum mechanics is playing
a big role we we can use quantum theory
is really well understood in regimes
where gravity is not that strong gravity
is really well understood in regimes
where you don't need to worry about
quantum mechanics but we know both have
to exist we know we have to be able to
understand the world with a macroscopic
and the microscopic and there are
regimes where but these two clash and
the black hole is a regime where you
have the world of the microscopic
quantum theory and the world of high
strength gravitational fields coming
together and a manifestation of this
problem is this information issue
because it's defined simply in terms of
its mass its angular momentum and its
charge it's got is what's known as no
hair there's nothing coming out to tell
you what spit gone in there the world of
quantum mechanics on the other hand
should also be able to describe this
process in the world of quantum
mechanics that is what's known as a wave
function it's integral to the world of
quantum theory that we can keep track of
this wave function we solve it by the
Schrodinger equation knowing about this
wave function tells us about the
probabilities of everything we always
expect probabilities to add to one if
they don't then it's about is that you
know something's wrong with our system
when you lose information it means that
this wavefunction no longer is
deterministic in the sense that you lose
that ability to have probabilities
adding up to one something's gone wrong
with your world of quantum mechanics but
we believe our world of quantum
mechanics so we have to be able to
reconcile this classical picture of the
black hole where the information gets
lost so this quantum mechanical picture
where we know the information shouldn't
get lost we need to be able to retrieve
it and in order to do it you're having
to match these two together the very
existence of black holes and a
singularity that you seemed it looks
like you have at the center of them
tells you that Einstein's theory is not
a complete theory it's at best an
effective theory there needs to be
replaced by something else when you
start talking about you know high
energies strong
gravitational fields and so on and so
forth in these that you need something
else which is most likely string theory
I guess it's believed that the Centers
of galaxies have got these super massive
black holes right books of billions of
solar masses which actually raises an
interesting question how did they form
right how did how do these have time to
I think there's maybe some cosmic
strength involved but no one likes that
idea
I'm just hoping they'll keep finding
these supermassive black holes earlier
and earlier and earlier and earlier to
eventually has just not been enough time
for black holes to coalesce and you need
another seed something like a super like
a massive cosmic string but anyway
that's just my own pet hope is it
possible that as you start reconciling
quantum mechanics and general relativity
and understanding black holes better
that singularities could come under
threat and people might think oh it's
okay there is actually a little bit of
volume there yes absolutely and I think
the majority I don't about the majority
but a lot of people that think about
what will be the effect of quantum
mechanics is that that singularity which
again is a breakdown of your
demonstrates a breakdown of your field
equations the breakdown of your
mathematics that singularity will get
smoothed out example of a star or object
whose gravity was so great that light
couldn't escape from it so basically
what's being hinted at here for the
first time is a black hole of the
existence of bodies under either of
these circumstances we could have no
information from sight